after nearly nine years we're getting
our first playable taste of Final
Fantasy 15 with episode dusk a 15 looks
like the most promising final fantasy in
a while with other recent titles
dividing the fandom we finally remember
the series golden age spanning its birth
on the NES to Final Fantasy 10 on the
PlayStation to make no mistake we're
excited for 15 but we've been hurt
before so here are a few lessons we
think it can learn from the series
classic titles the overworld is key in a
good RPG classic Final Fantasy titles
took this to heart building sprawling
maps that made the world feel huge and
lived in many allowed you to traverse
them on foot searching for the forest
cave or city in which your next
objective SAT some areas head side
quests where you could glean some extra
Gil experience points and even new
characters but more recent titles
notably 13 are linear to the point of
being hallways guiding you from point A
to point B there is a thrill to running
around green fields as a Dane and final
fantasy nine or jumping on an airship to
another continent in 6 giving players
the freedom to explore and discover
things on their own added depth to the
experience from what we've seen a 15 it
looks like a semi linear experience we
do know you can walk or drive across the
entire map and the demo features the
party roaming freely in large areas what
we don't know is if areas will be
blocked off until the story progresses
their previous games bent these rules a
bit allowing you to familiarize yourself
with places that wouldn't become a big
deal until later one of the best
examples of this is how final fantasy
nine treats introducing playable
character quinny-quinn quina lives in
cuse marsh a tiny area accessible early
on but not important until halfway
through disc 1 if you go to the marsh
after wrapping up things in lindblom you
can recruit quina however you can also
choose to avoid the marsh until after
completing three more areas during which
time you can get Quinn up pretty much
whenever depending on when you recruit
quina the story changes and you could
recruit not one but two optional
characters in Final Fantasy 7 yuffie and
Vincent which also impacted the story
this kind of non-linearity gives you
more control in what is already a highly
scripted story it's immersive in ways
guiding characters down to singular path
is
not even if you jam that hallway with
pit stops for cutscenes it also makes
side quests and activities feel more
organic you can play blitzball anytime
you go to lucca in Final Fantasy 10 you
can breed chocobos at your leisure in
seven and don't forget triple triad and
tetra master the in-game collectible
card battling games in 8 and 9
populating the world with smaller
activities that don't involve saving it
makes things feel more real more
complete so what are the implications of
15 s one giant map does this mean
everything will be open from the start
similar to the first part of 9 or will
we be limited by the narrative final
fantasy is known for its colorful casts
protagonists antagonists and PCs you
watch them fight struggle and sometimes
die strong characters are vital because
if your character is weak sauce your
audience's interest in powering through
their adventure will be watery 2 15's
Noctis appears to be the primary focus
as far as characters go and if he's
going to be up front he should be the
most complex his most recent predecessor
lightning is a badass in her own right
but most of the time that's her only ski
remember clouds horrible PTSD after
watching his friend die and then he
lived as his friend mixing up his own
memories and leading a genuinely painful
existence to watch let alone play
through we need that a protag that's
relatable but not boring complicated but
not untouchable also key a good bad guy
we don't quite know who the big daddy is
in 15 but we're hoping he or she recalls
those who came before like kefka palazzo
the sassy mage and clown makeup who
destroyed the world with a smile and 6
he's the perfect balance of entertaining
and threatening chaotic you'll at its
finest when he was on screen it was all
about him but when he wasn't you still
felt his ominous presence looming over
all the triple threat of ject see more
and yu yevon in 10 did it as well tended
an excellent job of building up a
multi-tiered menace presenting danger
from all sides and taking the entire
game to unravel the emotional
complications that came with it 7 did
this to a disturbed guy with a sword
seeking out his own brand of justice and
on top of that the less than
well-intentioned Shinra corporation
rufus in the turks were interesting
complex another thing to worry about but
another set of characters you couldn't
wait to encounter
recent Final Fantasy games haven't had
the most interesting or relatable or
understandable villains Caius ballad
came close in final fantasy 13-2 with
his brooding vow to save his only friend
from an eternity of torment but
lightning returns watered down his
madness making his final confrontation
more cheesy than cathartic we're hoping
that 15 can learn from this setting up a
complex antagonistic presence and
pinning players under non-stop pressure
that brings us to a point that latter
day final fantasies have struggled with
we need narratives with meaningful
complexity final fantasy 12 was a
reskinned less interesting Star Wars the
13 trilogy could have been a solid story
but was thinned out across too many
games and these stories always start
with the opening cutscene the first ten
minutes of a game are crucial to
conveying tone in setting the stage in
terms of what players can expect many
Final Fantasy titles go right for the
cold open sea Final Fantasy 6 and the
march of the magitek armor sevens
bombing mission 8 slippery fatali you
remember those cutscenes there would
hooked you when sin crashed the Blitz
ball game those first notes of other
worlds stuck with you forever if you're
going to demand a 50-plus our investment
for one game you need a multi-level plot
with even pacing Final Fantasy 7 has
great narrative design you have cloud
who is part of an eco-terrorism group
trying to take down a mega-corporation
harvesting the world's energy to power
civilization which is also killing the
planet cloud used to work for said
corporation and while their lost one
friend to death and at mother to madness
his repressed memories bubble up through
the entire game and every character you
roll into your party has deep investment
in this story's outcome or something
riding on the narrative as a player we
require characters to be invested in
their own game otherwise why would we
and peppered throughout all of this of
course are powerful scenes moments of
dramatic tension segments that make you
tingly these are the high points pieces
that never leave you finding out sin is
your dad and then having to kill your
own summons garnet forgiving queen
brahne a as she lies dying on the beach
eros is death cell a suicide attempt the
Opera seen these moments work because
they're populated with strong characters
you have to give a character life before
you can throw them into a high-tension
situation or kill them off it's why it
was hard to care when Sarah turned into
a crystal in 13 she
was boring whatever but with the
franchise's almost 30 years of lessons
learned Final Fantasy 15 is poised to
stab us through the heart once more
Final Fantasy 15 already has us
trembling with optimism we hope Square
Enix has been listening to its fans and
reached back into the series history for
elements that worked well before there's
a lot of potential here for Final
Fantasy 15 so long as developers aren't
afraid to listen to its predecessors
[Music]